hey guys dr. Berg here in this video I want to
discuss probably one of the most important body
systems that you have it's the digestive system
ok so you have 33 feet of intestines and that's a
like you can mention a water hose in your backyard
it's a very long hose and it's all wrapped around
and there's a lot of things that happen from start
to finish so let's just time to take from the top
you've got the stomach here which normally what's
interesting about the stomach is that people don't
realize how acid the stomach should be if you
understand pH neutral is 7 and it goes down to
be more acid and higher to be more alkaline for
every number let's say we go from 7 to 6 going
down that's 10 times more acid so it it compounds
so you can imagine a pH of 1 to 3 that is super
super acidic okay that's what the stomach should
be normally and the stomach actually helps you
release the stomach releases the acid triggers
enzymes that then help you break down protein so
they have very powerful proto lytic enzymes so
if there's a problem with the valve on the top
of the stomach then that enzyme gets up into
the esophagus they can literally digest your
tissues up into your throat so it's that powerful
it helps you absorb minerals so if you don't have
the right acid in your stomach you can't absorb
like iron you become anemic like even b12 will
not be absorbing either and that's another type
of anemia it also kills microbes because microbes
have a hard time living in that acid and either
even h pylori which is a very nasty bacteria that
causes ulcers and other issues if your stomach is
very acidic that thing will stay in a mission or
not invade your tissues but if the stomach is not
asked enough it will not release these to other
organs called the pancreas and the gallbladder so
what controls a pancreas in and the gallbladder
is really the pH of the stomach pH of that stomach
also controls the valve of the top of the stomach
so without that stomach being acidic you you
can get GERD acid reflux and then people take
any acids which is the exact opposite but what
happens if you you can't release the pancreas
now we don't we don't get the release of enzymes
so the pancreas has all these different enzymes
for carbohydrates proteins fats collagen you name
it and it's constantly released depending on which
you eat so signals from your mouth are telling
the pancreas what to release and what to create
when you start eating so so we have this enzyme
breakdown and then we have the gallbladder release
bile bile helps you break down fats break down fat
so you can absorb fat side with vitamins vitamin
A D and K and then also help you it helps you
detoxify certain chemicals in the liver so without
the gallbladder we can't get that full detox
let these two work together and then the bile is
alkalyn so it helps to neutralize this incredibly
strong acid coming into the small intestine so if
we didn't have the bile we couldn't neutralize
that and you would get an ulcer in your small
intestine and then we have the pancreas that also
makes this other alkaline fluid called bicarbonate
that helps neutralize the acid at this point too
so we go from a strong acid to a very alkaline
fluid inside the small intestine so the small
intestine is alkaline okay and it's so funny
when people say well you need to be alkaline well
what part of the body you're talking about because
your stomach better not the alkaline definitely
the small intestine should be alkaline but the
large intestine should be acidic so you have
different PHS so now in the small intestine this
is where 90% of the digestion occurs and you have
helped though you have microbes you have a lot of
microbes in fact in your body you have a thousand
trillion bacteria or microbes in your body outside
and inside that's a thousand trillion that's a lot
you only have a hundred trillion cells so these
bacteria or these microbes have are ten times
more than your own self so if you take a body
it's mostly microbes so but they're very small
so you don't there's like probably about three
or four maybe five pounds of microbes per body
weight but the microbes basically help you break
down your food and help so you can absorb the food
there's thousands tens of thousands of different
strains of microbes in your gut you have good
bacteria and then you have bad bacteria they're
called pathogenic now antibiotics destroy both
good and bad bacteria what's happening now is
the bad bacteria is adapting to the antibiotics
and they're becoming more resistant so now the
antibiotics don't work but the good news is
this that the good bacteria also adapts to the
antibiotics if it didn't you'd be probably be dead
by now so your microbes are very intelligent and
they have developed new strategies of surviving
so if you take a let's say someone comes in your
house and they try to steal something and then you
take a bat and you whack them right well the next
time they come in their house they're they wear a
helmet so these microbes basically have different
ways of adapting to survive one of the interesting
strategies some of these microbes pulled off is
they basically can mimic and adapt to your vitamin
D receptors they mimic the vitamin D receptor so
when your vitamin D goes into the wrong receptor
it doesn't work anymore so it's just as fascinated
because you need vitamin D for the immune system
so there's all these different types of strategies
that use one type of micro adapted without a
cell wall so they can move into the joints and
then they can travel and they can do this and they
can hide so your immune system can't detect them
very intelligent sneaky little guys but thank
goodness that our good bacteria also adapt so
we have 90% of the nutrient nutrition absorption
occurs at this level with other another thing
that's interesting about this is that you
have something called the enteric nervous
system so you have the sympathetic which is a
flight-or-fight that's like the stress nervous
system and then we have the parasympathetic which
is part of the rest and digest which controls a
lot of this - that's that's kind of like the
opposite of the stress nervous system but then
you have the enteric which controls like all this
intestines and the peristalsis the pumping action
of the whole thing and if years someone cut your
spinal column for example you could this will
still work because it's an independent nervous
system it can work on its own that's what I call
the second brain but the challenge is that a
lot of the information that happens down here
is transmitted up to the brain so whatever's going
on your digestion can affect your mood you could
it could have create depression anxiety and a
lot of tension in your neck and even a lot of
headaches so it's interesting how the digestion
can affect your mood and also your mood could
affect your digestion both ways because it's a
second brain the bacteria also makes a lot of B
vitamins so what happens when I see people with
vitamin B deficiencies it's not because they're
not consuming them is because they don't have
the microbes or they they don't have the good
digestive system to absorb those vitamin B
over those B vitamins or they they make them
but they can't get absorbed because the surface
lining of the intestines is damaged so I'll get
to that in a little bit but what these microbes
eat or consume is fiber preferably when we want
to feed them a vegetable fiber and they turn it
into something called butyrate which is a type of
acid that then will feed the colon cells so it's
it's interesting these microbes actually exchange
with us we help them they we provide a house and
they give us food as well so that's what happens
in the small intestine and the large intestine is
mainly responsible for reabsorption of water and
minerals but this is where you have the highest
concentration of microbes so without the microbes
here you'll get diarrhea okay the little little
roots that occur in a small intestine are called
little villi they're upside down roots and that's
where it absorbs and you have like a million
bacteria per millimeter like a real small surface
area there's a so many compacted microbes in there
that are supposed to help you absorb and write
when it gets absorbed it goes right into the
lymphatic system 80% of your lymphatic system is
surrounding your intestines so 85% of your immune
system is really connected to your gut and it's
there and it's kind of like immigration to give
these microbes a stamp of approval or not approval
to not let them through so there's a barrier there
that resists microbes that are unfriendly so
when you destroy these little so-called villi
or little roots you get this small surface area
where you now you can't you lose your immigration
so now my unfriendly microbes can innervate and
start to go into the lymphatic system and create
health for the immune system that's where you get
autoimmune diseases that's where the immune system
you know starts giving the wrong information and
attacking it's not creating antibodies for your
own tissue it's like self attack so you have a
lot of inflammatory conditions that originated
from this lining that you lose the structure
okay so there's a couple things that you can
do number one you have to build up the flora and
I think the best way is to take something called
effective microbes I'll put a link down there
I'm not affiliated I don't get any Commission's
or anything but I'll put a link down there of
effective microbes and you can check it out but
effective microbes is the symbiotic a group of
microbes that basically all live on each other
so they kind of work together and you want to
take very very very small amounts starting out
because if you have too many unfriendly strains
you can create a war so you want to take them
right before you go to bed and then they'll grow
in your system over a period of time so effective
microbes are very important and then to retrain
your immune system your t-cells and start to put
back that immune system I recommend something
called colostrum and again I'll put a link down
there below I'm not affiliated with any companies
but this is a really good thing too your immune
system and it's really really good for rheumatoid
arthritis it's good for inflammation it's good for
autoimmune it's good for allergies it's really
good for sinus mucus it's good for any type of
inflammatory condition but I will say when you
take this start off taking very small amounts
maybe 1/4 of a teaspoon before bed why because if
you don't have a good immune system you're going
to stir up a hornet's nest and you're gonna get
more mucus that it's gonna kick in there so you
always want to start very small over a gradual
period of time to start introducing these 2
things so and I also recommend al glutamine -
those three are really good to start building
up the intestinal wall and then over time you'll
start getting your immune system back ok so I
hope that kind of gave you a summary of how this
digestive system works and put your comments below